MaMartine Biron, Hélènene Buzzei
etet Luc Ferrandez.
BoBonsoir à v vous trois.
- - Bonsoir.
- - Martine, ça fait un bout de
tetemps, bonsoir! Ça fait plaisr
dede vous voir. C'est tout
mémélanger, le premier sujet, le
raras-le-bol des camionneurs.
IlIl y a cette pression pour
dédéconfiner, alors qu'on
dédéconfiner ailleurs. Martine,e
cocommence avec vous. Est-ce qun
ararrive à u un nouveau moment,à
unune nouvelle relation entre ls
cicitoyens et les mesures
sasanitaires?
- - Je pense que oui. Il y a une
rerencontre très s importante qa
dédébuter dans une demi-heure de
lala cellule de crise, c'est-à--
didire les experts de la santé
pupublic et le politique, dans e
prpremier ministre. On va prende
dedes décisions sur... on va
reregarder les chiffres. On
s's'attend ce que ça sonne trèss
lolongue rencontre. Je vais vous
didire ce que sous-entend. Ça
rereste à c confirmer. Il pourry
avavoir un point de presse du
prpremier ministre demain. Ce
ququ'il y a dans la, c'est la fn
dede certaines mesures, comme ls
rerestaurants. Les bulle familie
auaussi on donnerait un peu d'a.
JeJe vous rappellerai qu'à N Nën
avavait le droit à 1 10 personns
dadans les maisons. Et les spor.
J'J'interviens pour la culture,
leles salles de spectacles, les
jejeans et les bords. Je vous le
coconfirme pas, mais c'est dans
leleur au moment où on se parle.
- - Et comment ça ne pourrait ps
êêtrtre dans l'air, alors que
l'l'Ontario un peu ouvert la
mamachine?
- - Et je pense que les Québécos
sosont de plus en plus conscien.
PePendant les premièreres vague,
leles Québécois se sont faits
vavacciner pour se faire protég.
DaDans la vague actuelle, les
QuQuébécois ont la conviction
ququ'ils se font vacciner pour
prprotéger le systèmeme de santt
çaça c'est différent, c'est
didifficile de les mobiliser. La
sisituation est différente entre
l'l'Ontario et le Québec. Mais n
esest encore dans un systèmemeùl
y y a peu de lits, trop de
pepersonnes aux soins intensifs,
enen hospitalisation. Convaincu
QuQuébécois qu'il faut qu'il se
vavaccine pour cette raison-là,,
c'c'est très s difficile.
- - Hélènene, je le disais, c'et
cecertain camionneur, pas tous.n
vovoit une colèrere qui va passe
lala Colombie-Britannique jusquà
OtOttawa. Jusqu'à q quel point s
rereprésentatives? Monsieur
TrTrudeau a dit on ne va pas
rerevenir en arrièrere évidemmet
papas pour les vaccins, mais qud
mmêmeme, c'est partout.
- - Oui, vous avez souvent poséa
ququestion à v vos intervenants
plplutôt t en émission sur le ft
quque mêmeme si Monsieur Trudeau
inintervenait ça ne changerait
ririen, parce que les États-Unis
imimposent une vaccination
obobligatoire pour les camionnes
auaussi. Les camionneurs craignt
auaussi la prochaine étape, c'e-
àà-d-dire que Ottawa veut instar
auaussi une obligation vaccinale
popour les camionneurs inter
prprovinciaux.
EtEt c'est ça qui fait beaucoup
pepeur. J'ai été étonné de voir
totoutes ces associations de
cacamionnages se dissocier de la
mamanifestation qui est t en co,
paparce que lorsque l'on leur
paparlait il y a deux ou trois
sesemaines, ou quelques jours, s
sosont complètetement catastrops
papar ses obligation vaccinale.
CeCes associations demandent
égégalement le recul d'Ottawa, n
rerefuse de s'associer à c ces s
ququi sont plus visibles, plus,
pepeut-êtrtre, extrêmemes dans r
opopposition mesurent vaccinale.
EtEt encore une fois, on assistà
cecette mêmeme polarisation, c'-
àà-d-dire, ou bien est entièrert
popour les mesures
gogouvernementales, où en est ue
frfrange extrémiste.
- - Mais Monsieur Cadieux, de
l'l'association de camionnages
QuQuébec, il était... on voyait
ququ'il disait que la situation
ététait difficile, catastrophiqe
dadans certains endroits, mais l
nene voulait pas monter la
prpression, peut-êtrtre parce ql
nénégocie et qu'il veut convaine
leles provinces, Canada, qui ne
veveut pas appliquer le passepot
auau Canada.
- - C'est ce qu'il y a un peu de
cecela, mais quand on interroge
ceces camionneurs et qu'on tombe
susur les deux ou trois qui nous
didisent : je ne veux pas me fae
ininjecter un produit dont je ne
coconnais pas le contenu. Tout à
cocoup on ne pas d'êtrtre contaé
papar ce discours. N'empêchche l
y y a un argumentaire très s vae
afafin de valoir du fait qu'il y
a.a... que les camionneurs sont
dedes travailleurs majoritairemt
sosolitaires. Le bienfait
sasanitaire de cette obligation
vavaccinale n'a pas été démontr.
EtEt quand Monsieur Trudeau dit
quque la meilleure façon de ne s
nunuire aux chaînenes
d'd'approvisionnement c'est de e
fafaire vacciner, ce n'est pas
tetellement vrai. On ne sait que
si o on peut êtrtre vacciné, ont
totomber malade. Mêmeme si on na
papas l'hôpipital, ont tousse. t
ceces maladies...
- - Un petit mot sur les
cacamionneurs,?
- - La nature mêmeme du camionnr
c'c'est de la nature solitaire.t
enencore là i il faut trouver le
sesens de l'opération et m motir
leles camionneurs à c comprendr.
PaParce qu'il y a plusieurs
éléléments qui leur portent à
cocomprendre... à c croire qu'ie
dedevrait pas êtrtre sujet à u e
ininterdiction. Par ailleurs on
sasait que selon été les héros e
lala premièrere et la deuxièmeme
vavague. Pendant les deux
prpremièreres vagues, c'était ds
héhéros. Il faut les traiter coe
cecela. Il ne faut pas tout à cp
l'l'effort comme des
rérécalcitrants. Il faut se
rarappeler ce contexte.
- - Et Martine, ses obligations
dadans les grandes surfaces. Vos
nonous dîtetes qu'on annonce des
asassouplissements demain. Est-e
quque ça serait pas un double
didiscours? C'est-à-d-dire que t
unune mesure qui est perçue come
cecertains comme exagérée. Commt
vava concilier tout cela?
- - C'est un équilibre qui est
trtrès s fragile. Ça peut touchr
auaussi les camionneurs. C'est n
éqéquilibre très s fragile, pare
quque...
MaMais en mêmeme temps, si on vt
memettre les noms vacciner ou p,
ilil est pénalisé parce qu'ils e
veveulent pas se protéger et
prprotéger la collectivité, on
imimpose des obligations à d des
gegens qui sont vaccinés, des
prpropriétaires d'entreprise, ds
didirigeants de commerce, on les
oboblige avoir du personnel pour
susurveiller les noms vacciner.n
veverra, surtout les cahiers, ls
enentreprises entrepreneurs qui
vevendent du matériel de
coconstruction. C'est extrêmemet
cocompliqué. Mon vous suivre das
leles grandes sauf faces si,
efeffectivement, il y a plusieus
nonoms vacciner qui décode avec
totous les moyens, c'est-à-d-die
ququ'il faut quelqu'un pour tesr
leles passeport vaccinal, ça prd
dede la sécurité, ça devient
exextrêmemement compliqué. Et ct
didifficile.
- - Et quelqu'un qui doit aller
chchez Costco, c'est... on doit
exexporter par un employé.
DrDr Boileau, je reviens avec
cecela. Dr Boileau a dit à c ces
ququestions : oui, c'est
prprécisément parce qu'on va les
lalaisser chez eux. S'ils sortet
totous en mêmeme temps, les noms
vavaccinaient, Thérèsese dite ar
trtrop d'infection pour le syste
hohospitalier. On sent que ce
n'n'est pas pour les emmerdeurs,
c'c'est pour les cloîtrtrer pre,
LuLuc?
- - Absolument, mais à ce e mom-
llà, , pourquoi pas l'obligation
vavaccinale? Parce que rendu à e
niniveau de cumul de mesures por
leles cloîtrtrer, les écuries ee
guguillemets, il y a des
dédéclarations qui ont précédé :
enenvie d'aller rendre leur vie
didifficile. Mais est-ce que ce
cucumul n'est pas rendu aussi
lolourd qu'un obligation
vavaccinale?
- - Je n'y crois pas trop, je
pepense que c'est pour précisémt
memerdier les noms vaccinaient.
PaParce qu'encore la preuve
sasanitaire, elle n'est pas faie
dadans les grandes surfaces.
DaDans un restaurant on enlèveve
nonotre masque, c'est plus
évévident.t. Mais dans un Canadn
TiTires, personne ne nous a
dédémontré que c'était le cas.
- - Madame Anglade, du côtété
popolitique, elle a décidé de ne
plplus participer aux rencontres
avavec le premier ministre, on
rerencontre le vendredi, des
rerencontres virtuelles. On va
l'l'écouter, elle nous explique
popourquoi. Elle a dit : une
esescouade. Elle propose une
esescouade COVID-19 qui
dédéciderait, d'où émaneraient s
dédécisions de de santé publiqu.
JeJe vais vous demander ce que
vovous en comprenez. Tout d'abo,
MaMadame Anglade.
DODOMINIQUE ANGLADE, cheffe,
PaParti libéral du Québec
- - J'ai tâchché d'amener
dedes recommandations puis de
didire qu'on devait le faire
dadans le cadre de la santé
nanational de manièrere publiqu,
onon a refusé ça.
IlIls ont refusé qu'il y ait la
prprésence d des médias, ils ont
rerefusé qu'il y ait la présence
dede la santé publique. Je me ss
ququand mêmeme prêtétée au jeu r
coconstater que, finalement,
çaça marche pas. Et je pense
ququ'on est rendu à u une étape,
llà, , où les gens sont tellemet
fafatigués, tellement tannés,
onon est tellement... t'sais...
totout le monde est à c cran. B,
ququand quelque chose marche pa,
ilil faut qu'on se le dise, là,,
pupuis qu'on se donne les moyens
dede réussir, là. . Il faut qu'n
sese dise les choses franchemen:
çaça marche pas, ça marche pas!
TrTrouvons-nous d'autres
mémécanismes qui vont faire
enen sorte que l'approche va
mamarcher cette fois-ci.
- - Prenons le premier élément :
lele refus de participer aux
rerencontres.
- - Elle plafonne à 2 20 %, a éé
rereçu un coup de massue dans ls
rarangs libéraux. Ça veut dire e
soson congrès s n'a rien fait.Ça
n'n'a pas fait bouger l'aiguill.
Alors il faut voir les choses.
AuAu sein de son caucus mêmeme,t
mmêmeme dans les grandes libéra,
c'c'est-à-d-dire les vieux libéx
ququi mêlalaient encore. On troe
quque Madame Anglade n'est pas
asassez fonceuse, agressive, ele
dedevrait prendre la balle au bd
unun peu plus souvent. Avec ces
rérésultats, on est rendu à c ct
enendroit-là. . Elle a choisi de
papas participer, de faire une
mamanchette, en claquant la pore
dedes rencontres qui ont lieu ue
fofois par semaine, jusqu'à c ce
lala cession commence avec les
chchefs d'opposition et le premr
miministre. Il restait une
vevendredi, une la semaine
prprochaine, et après s c'est
teterminé. Elle se retrouve dans
unune situation de chaise vide.
C'C'est sa décision à e elle. Ct
unune décision un peu douteuse,
leles gens autour d'elle se
dedemandent un peu pourquoi ella
fafait cela, parce qu'elle va un
pepeu le recevoir au visage.
- - Et Luc, l'escouade, d'abord
llà-d-dessus, et elle dit aussi
ququ'il faut former une escouad.
CÇa revient peu à c ce que les s
veveulent de...
- - Je pense que oui, et je pene
quque c'est la santé publique
dedevrait aviser les élus.
JeJe trouve qu'elle a raison. Et
jeje pense qu'elle a fait un bon
cocoup. Ça roulait toute la fine
sesemaine, ça a roulé depuis
ququ'elle a fait son annonce, ts
leles micros du Québec lui ont
papassé sous le nez pour savoir
popourquoi elle fait ça. Est-ce
ququ'elle a bien expliqué, est-e
ququ'elle a été assez mordante?e
nene sais pas. Mais elle a réusi
soson coup.
- - Vous, vous dîtetes que ça éé
efefficace?
- - Oui, je pense que oui.
- - Hélènene?
- - Je comprends pourquoi il ne
veveut plus y participer. On
coconstate que c'est un peu
papartout au pays, un
ininsatisfaction grandissante ds
gegens, et elle ne veut plus avr
lala êtrtre embrigadé par le
gogouvernement, d'êtrtre côtetee
avavec le gouvernement. C'est ue
fafaçon d'êtrtre politique prene
acacte de cette colèrere. Mais t
esescouade COVID-19, c'est une
ststratégie qui consiste à t ter
unun peu le vent, et de dire la
mmêmeme chose qu'en entendant la
popopulation, de véhiculer, de
rerelayer les critiques, mais ne
papas vraiment proposer des
memesures. C'est une façon
esessentiellement de récupérer a
cocolèrere citoyenne, mais sans
nénécessairement proposer des
alalternatives très s concrètet.
- - Martine, c'est important coe
; ; parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
gegens, et Legault le répétait
sosouvent, il y a beaucoup de gs
ququi disent : on ne peut pas
dédépolitiser, parce qu'il
popourrait y avoir d'autres
fafacteurs, la santé mentale des
mamains des jeunes. Les sports,
j'j'espèrere que ça sera annoncé
dedemain.
- - C'est un peu dans
l'l'argumentaire de Madame
AnAnglade. Et sa proposition est
inintéressante parce que, dans e
fofond, ce qu'elle souhaitait et
elelle a des jeudis dans les
rerencontres qu'elle a eues avec
lele premier ministre les partis
d'd'opposition, les partis
d'd'opposition devraient membree
lala cellule de crise. Ils diset
ququ'ils ont peu d'information,
ququ'il manque de transparence.t
c'c'est vrai que ces réunions ne
sosont pas très s instructives r
eueux. Ils sont devant plusieurs
fafaits accomplis. Mais on est
dadans la perception et c'est un
pepeu ça qu'elle veut, Madame
AnAnglade, proposer, faire parti
dede la solution, mais en
s's'excluant de ces rencontres,
elelle a donné... l'effet qu'ele
lalaisse, c'est : je veux
cocollaborer, mais je ne suis ps
prprêt t alpha.
- - Très s bien, on va voir la e
dedes choses.
L'L'élément qui revient partout,
c'c'est que l'écoeurante était .
LuLuc, on va parler aux 18 heurs
plplus longuement, est-ce qu'il
popourrait y avoir de fausses
bobonnes idées, comme Mike
WhWhitehead qui dit : je vais
ofoffrir à l la ville des micros
tetendres, je vous les donne, ms
lala ville n'en veut pas. Toutea
fifin de semaine, Plante a dû
exexpliquer pourquoi.
- - Moi je pense que c'est une
mamauvaise idée. Prenons comme
exexemple l'installation de
totoilettes publiques dans Vill-
MaMarie comme projet pilote. Dès
lele début, il a été convenu que
cecette toilette publique ne
popouvait pas fonctionner sans
ququ'il y ait une personne
alalentours. L'éventail de
prproblèmemes qui pouvaient se
prproduire, ce sont tous produi.
C'C'était utilisé comme des liex
popour s'injecter. Il y avait de
lala prostitution. Les lumièrers
ététaient toujours cassées.
- - Ce qui peut êtrtre séduisan,
dadans les faits, c'est plus
cocompliqué. Martine?
- - C'est difficile de coiffer c
susur le terrain de Montréal, ms
ququand mêmeme, je regardais unu
memes notes, je regardais ce qui
s's'était passé en janvier 2021.
VoVous rappellerez l'homme qui t
dédécédé dans une toilette
chchimique parce que son refuge
ététait fermé. Je trouvais qu'iy
avavait un décalage entre le
teterrain ce que disait Valérie
PlPlante. Bien, il manque de
plplace.
- - Il y a toujours le risque ac
dedes installations comme ça, de
pépérenniser des villages
d'd'itinérance. On a eu ce
prproblèmeme à G Gatineau. Il ya
pepeut-êtrtre d'autres solution,
paparce qu'on sait que
l'l'itinérance est beaucoup plus
prprofond. Ce n'est pas juste de
trtrouver un toit pour la nuit.
ElElle se manifeste plus par
pépériode de grand froid. Ici, n
a a réquisitionné les hôtetels e
mamanièrere ponctuelle pendant s
grgrands froids.
- - Merci à v vous trois. On n'n
rereparlera au Téléjournal de